[Music]
Jeff Snyder here and it is my last shift
at the Kia Telluride summer suite and I
am here with the team behind the last
shift these guys are coming in let's
start with that director Andrew cone
where did this all come from tell me
about the genesis of this project the
genesis no joking sort of most of my
writing starts with a character you know
I started with this character who loved
his job it was kind of based on people
that I had met throughout my life I
worked a lot of crappy jobs and you know
started with a character started to
build awesome themes through there and
just wanted to tell a story of regular
people you know people you don't often
see on screen I wanted to tell it
through a comedy and a movie about race
and class and the working poor that can
just sort of shed light on some things
in a nuanced and sort of not didactic
way so it was a long process about two
years writing the script and yeah share
the movie tonight
well Richard you play a fast food worker
who is retiring and you're training your
replacement can you tell me you you and
Shane what you know what attracted you
to these roles how'd you make him your
own well we're kind of all we had there
was it was there was the writing you
know the writing it's incredible it's
really great writing great characters
you know actors are selfish you read the
payment unless there's anybody else in
this you know and I love I love the take
on this guy you know I grew up with him
the movie takes place in in the Midwest
I grew up in the Midwest and you know I
knew these guys in school and I just
thought he really found that voice of
these kind of lost folks Shane yeah I
would I would say the writing as well
you know just seeing that everything was
on the page all the nuances of you know
of what the character had to say and and
also his character you know Stanley was
so Corky and and but it wasn't over the
top it was very grounded in in his in
his truth and so me just wanting to play
with with that kind of character and
then Richard as well and you know I
don't want him to be able to to play
with him I'm just really excited me I
really did and and Devine and Allison
and AD where do you all fit into this
story because unfortunately I haven't
seen it yet sometimes you got to do
these interviews or you haven't seen the
movie I can't wait to see it I've heard
good things but so how do you guys fit
into the story know I'm from the Midwest
and I know one of the producers run New
York so and I knew his work and I know
Richards work and I talked to Andrew and
it just seemed like a good who do you
play in the film in I play Dale I I play
Jevons like parole agent officer okay
and I got to come in just for a day and
and play with Shane you get to play a
little bit of a hard-ass no not at all
bright eyed and ready to help people
dream big G I play their boss yeah now
have any of you guys ever worked at like
a fast food job or anything when you're
younger I've worked every [ __ ] job known
to man pretty much I mean I think the
highlight of my shitty jobs were
teaching driver's training but yeah I
worked at Burger King when I was 15
years old and I worked at KFC some of
the some of the dialogue and characters
are taken the journey along the way
what's the toughest part of a job like
that is it dealing with customers or is
it sweating your ass off behind the
grill I was 15 years old I was so
excited to work that job I got my first
paycheck it was $75 I think I spent half
of it on like Burger King
I was like I had a paper route and I was
like I'm rich Jane I understand that
your character he has some provocative
politics that have gotten him into some
trouble he's worth whatever do what do
you mean I I don't know can you sort of
describe what those are and what makes
your character I'm gonna kind of edgy
you know I think he in the beginning of
the film just kind of passes off the
blame to other people which you know a
lot of us have a tendency to do at times
but I think you know as the film
progresses we see that he he learns to
take accountability for his actions he
learns to step up to the plate and in a
weird way I feel like he kind of gets
that from your character just seeing how
much you bring how much he brings to his
to his I always thought you look at me
he goes I'm gonna end up like that if I
don't change is that too but I think you
know he just bring Stanley is so
committed to the job whereas my
character comes in and is like what are
you doing like this is not it's not that
deep it's not that serious and for him
it is but yeah I think there's there's a
lot of growth that happens with my
character in that regard I feel like
there are a lot of really smart people
out there working low-wage jobs that
they feel maybe you know superior to and
I think they're gonna be able to relate
to this somehow yes well I mean we were
saying earlier to it's like we want we
want people to be able to look on the
screen and say oh I know that person
I've with that person or you know I work
with that person so hopefully they
relate to it in that way
daven you know I wanted to talk about
dolomite critics flip for your
performance and a lot of people felt
that you were unfairly snubbed do you
think that there's still like a Netflix
bias in the in the economy or you know
what I say
[Laughter]
okay please hire me again but what
exactly are you asking well just like
you know yes do you think that there's
that the Academy holds something against
Netflix or oh I don't know I guess
that's like is that a joke or is it a
rumor I don't really know I don't
believe in it because I think Netflix
you know employs half the industry yeah
I think I think Netflix drivers just to
getting out as much diversified content
as possible and I think they're really
focused on quality so if that ends up at
the end of the day meaning that that
then Garner's acclaimed projects so be
it I guess everyone else just has to I
don't know I really don't know I guess
it's just kind of like I guess it's the
kid on the block so then everyone just
has eyes on that person but what I hope
is that it changes a narrative for
everyone across the board and then more
people do diversify things but I really
hope the Academy is not making choices
just because they have personal feelings
about yeah I hope it's the work I think
Ted's gonna hire you again that was a
good answer
Andrew is this your first narrative
feature yeah I've been doing Docs for 10
years yeah can you talk about sort of
that transition how this was maybe
different for you oh it's different the
same I was surprised how well the skill
set transitioned to be honest you know
same approach just trying to make the
most honest choice you know trying to
get the most honest you know decision
that I can make and I think when one of
the things that was fun about working
with actors was I feel like I had a
really good grip on being able to read
body language and really do a lot of
listening I think it's as a director you
want to you want to do more listening
than talking and do you want to create a
set where people can take risks and give
people ownership over their performances
and you know really collaborate that's
what was exciting for me about it you
know making the transition
can everybody lifts lists off their
favorite fast-food joint I'm curious I'm
from Texas it's Whataburger obvious
what does it call Whataburger
Whataburger
yeah like Whataburger someone's smiling
back there hey Texas Arizona yes let's
go down the line Edie what's what's your
favorite fast-food joint oh right now
okay
I'm from LA he's gotta be in a now it's
gotta be that's cool
this is politically incorrect but I'm
gonna go with chick-fil-a and I am a
sucker for for chick-fil-a we don't
judge here at Collider okay this is like
veggie grill cow yeah why not veggie
grill yes girl I wanted to ask
so davon you just rap Lee Daniels new
movie about Billie Holiday right is
there anything you can say about then or
the role you play um I just did a movie
with Lee Daniels is about Billie Holiday
I think the working title is the United
States versus Billie Holiday and so it
examines the last 10 years of her life I
play her best friend named Rosalynn who
also was in her I guess what would have
been back then like her glam squad would
you like her hair and makeup in the
childhood best friends and it's really
cool and intense and it shows an
in-depth look that I think beyond what
we kind of like generally know about her
and how the government had a hand in all
of it okay and Shane did you just wrap
Charlie days directorial debut to have
that right not just but I did yeah Wow
any idea when we might see that when you
find out you tell me no I don't know I
don't know I hope soon though I'm really
excited to see that one that was a
really fun one Alison that we were
catching up beforehand I think I was one
of your very first interview you were
doctoring Fargo so so like I don't know
like I've sort of watched your career
since then can you tell me about that
journey since that first time that we
sat down and this was all so new to you
um Wow Wow that's a big question um yeah
no I think I mean obviously we're
mentoring Fargo afla Fargo sort of like
changed my life almost overnight and so
a lot has happened in the meantime
I get to do things like come to send
Sundance now which is your first time at
the festival my second time okay
yeah I'm still on Mars man it's still
the coolest thing I still am just really
just floating through it and Richard
you're also here with kajillion air both
Gillian air
I don't know how was it working with
Miranda July I feel like she's a lot
different than Andrew here extremely
different all ER yeah she's I mean
Miranda is like Miranda Miranda is she's
like nobody I've ever met yeah and
Andrew isn't either I mean but it's I
really love working with her I love her
brain I love the story she wrote it's
like where did this come from you know
and it didn't you after about two days
you guys oh it came from Miranda July I
mean she's really really great that
sounds like a fun one and do you think
of that will ever reboot married with
children me are you filming GMOs yeah
you and I started about a week yeah can
you say like what your role is what your
fine yeah I play a guy who's has tons of
money but lost the love of his life when
he was in college and it was his fault
and he wants
Bradley Cooper plays the lead he wants
him he's a medium he wants to see his
lost love he wants her to forgive him